[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so sally
weltweite gibt ein kleines fellinis
basic rezept und zwar mache es heute
waffeln und war nehme ich war immer
gerne buttermilch dafür die buttermilch
walking sind wirklich super was dich und
ich zeige euch heute ein paar kleine
geheimnisse wie die besten bei waffeln
gelingen
wir bereiten immer ganz gerne waffeln am
sonntag zum beispiel wenn ihnen mal
keine lust auf kochen habe und dann
stehen uns dafür in die küche und machen
den waffelteig denn jetzt wirklich super
schön vorbereitet und die grund lud
haben haben wir auch immer zu hause das
heißt waffeln gehen bei uns immer und
sind auch bei kindern immer sehr beliebt
ich sage ich jetzt mal die technik
flughafen und später was ihr noch
erweitern könnt für den wasserverbrauch
ist 350 gramm mehl 100 gramm stärke
eigenheit teelöffel backpulver einem
halben teelöffel natron und eine prise
150 g zucker etwa fanie lag bei 150 grad
flüssig geburt haben drei eier 750 gramm
pro tonne und von fetten das waffeleisen
50 den bug transfer erst einmal die
trockenen zutaten
dies erhöhe ich hier ich brauche immer
noch keine küchenmaschine geht alles
ganz einfach familien stärken habe ich
noch zucker backpulver nach und zwar
nachdem ich deshalb mir das so weil dann
das hat ein bisschen besser aussieht und
nach gebrauch immer zum aufgehen ein
bisschen sollte daher daneben auch die
butter mit dem schneebesen einfach ein
bisschen klümpchen frei
und jetzt kommen die restlichen zutaten
mit rein natürlich wann ihr extrakt aber
ihr könnt die waffe ist auch gerne
verfeinert wie ihr möchtet so hast du
auch mit etwas zitronenschale ablegt
oder auf andere aromen kommt die eier
mit reimen flüssigkeit pro tag
die buttermilch mit früchte ist erstmal
langsam und geht dann aber nur soviel
buttermilch mit dass so etwas ein sich
flüssiger teig entsteht der eben nicht
zu dick aber auch nicht so dumm sein
sollte und da kommt einfach darauf an
wie groß die eier war wegen etwa 500 550
gramm
[Musik]
so verpasste ein kurzes basic rezept
also fast fertig waffelteig auf der
sollte eben schön glatt seien keine
klümpchen mit drin haben und dann ist
auch wirklich perfekt und dann können
sie auch jederzeit gut vorbereiten und
im kühlschrank lagern und dann zum
beispiel für netbooks fire oder so
aufheben dem kühlschrank und dann bei
bedarf die waffeln aufbacken ich habe
zwar bleiben
ich habe jetzt das gibt's nur leider
nicht mehr und die ja die letzten die
werden jetzt im internet sehr teuer
verkaufen muss ich sagen gewendet
gehandelt ich hatte das glück dass ich
eine farbe und ansonsten ist einfach ein
ganz normales waffeleisen ich bin halt
die belgischen machen immer ganz gut ist
die demo schön dick werden weil die
einfach auf den kopf und ihnen saftig
sind aber die dünnen waffen gehen
genauso also diese frau verheiratet ist
wirklich für jedes waffeleisen geeignet
ich werde jetzt erst einmal das wasser
erhitzen und es dauert jetzt einfach ein
paar minuten und den derzeit kann ich
hier aufräumen
[Musik]
was geeignet war der tag durch jetzt
auch ein bisschen quellen und jetzt kann
ich erst mit etwas fleiß hätten
damit geht eben am einfachsten weil sie
das nicht habt könnt ihr natürlich auch
öl nehmen empfindet aber das spritzt
dann immer ein bisschen
deswegen finde ich damit sehr einfach
vor allem kann man eben ganz wenig wert
und ihr müsst ihr einfach schauen was
den waffen ihr habt also bei mir muss es
natürlich eine ordentliche menge rein
denn dass ein jetzt gemacht
diese zeigen kann ich auch umdrehen und
auf der anderen seite noch eine
auspacken
[Musik]
und da meldet die waffeln jetzt
hellbraun ausbacken je nachdem was die
masse leiden gehabt dauerte 73 minuten
fünf minuten ist einfach mal schauen die
erste vielleicht auch probieren die zeit
stoppen und dann könnte er bei der
nächsten wahl stellen
bei der pid geht das ist einfach hier
unten und ich kann die uhr laufen lassen
[Musik]
dabei die waffen fertig sind nämlich sie
heraus und damit sie nicht durchweichen
lege ich sie jetzt auf ein abkühlen
gitter dadurch werden sie auf dem hof
bleiben aber ihnen schön passte und
jetzt mache ich einfach alle waffen und
schnell aus
[Musik]
ich bin die waffe im fertig gebacken und
ich habe acht große waffe und daraus
bekommen das heißt mit seinen dicken
machen reisen falls er ein dünneres
abgehen wahrscheinlich etwa 16 bis 20
waffen
je nachdem wie gut es eben jetzt die
waffen könnt ihr übrigens auch ein
bisschen verfeinern das ist die basic
woche aber er könnte möchte statt
vanille auch zitronenschale dazugeben
ihr könnt sind mit reingeben kakaopulver
oder physische roulade ein bisschen rum
macht das ganze machen sich ein
automatischer zentrum rubinen mit
reingeben imbiss in beijings mit rein
schütten lebensmittelverarbeitung geben
also wirklich alles was euch dazu
einfällt und ich habe jetzt auch schon
ein video für euch vorbereitet was jetzt
bin nicht online kommt und zwar habe ich
da drei ideen die aus diesen waffeln
zubereiten können dann fühlt könnt ihr
eure eigenen ideen mit einbringen das
heißt zeit kreativ und backt waffeln und
uns wirklich immer super lecker und ich
wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß beim
nachkochen der rezepte findet ihr
auffällig mit praktika bis zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]
inkl